all this kind of Aura all this Mystique
his presence the way he behaves at the
board he he puts really so much energy
and he's too and there we go Bishop
Effigy is the on the board the line that
we discussed that it happened
Wesley so is about to survive and King
FC yes it
unbelievable I think that now I am the
V4 from the chair because this King yet
was kind of the super precise computer
move look at the body language of
obviously immediately different why
goodness Speedo we were just talking
about this trap that Wesley wrestling
set up and
here the point is that white cannot
anymore hang on to that F3 Pawn the H
Pawn is coming in H3 was a big threat
the only way to keep the game going
white has to fall back with the bishop
but now look at the position there is no
way for white to make progress anymore
Wesley is alive
he comes up with the King and there we
see handshakes as all the pieces have
gone off the board